Harrison Bucker giving his speech
for the ladies present today.
Congratulations on an amazing accomplishment.
You should be proud of all that you have achieved
to this point in your young lives.
I want to speak directly to you briefly because I think it is you,
the women, who have had the most diabolical lies told to you.
How many of you are sitting here now, about to cross this stage,
and are thinking about all the promotions and titles
you are going to get in your career?
Some of you may go on to lead successful careers in the world.
But I would venture to guess that the majority of you are most excited
about your marriage
and the children you will bring into this world.
I can tell you that my beautiful wife, Isabel,
would be the first to say that her life truly started
when she began living her vocation as a wife and as a mother.
I'm on the stage today unable to be the man I am
because I have a wife who leans into her location.
I'm beyond blessed with the many talents god has given me.
But it cannot be overstated that all of my success is made possible
because a girl I met in band class back in middle school would
convert to the faith,
become my wife,
and embrace one of the most important titles of all. Homemaker.